the x-men are not currently part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but if they
were the only x-man to survive the snap
would have spelled big trouble for
phonos speaking with IT ends up at noon
show Avengers and game directors Joe and
Anthony Russo revealed the one member of
the team they would have left standing
and they have some pretty solid
reasoning behind their choice the
Russo's conversation with IGN involved a
thought experiment in which the pair
were asked about several groups of
people some fictional and some nuts and
which members would have survived what
Marvel refers to as the decimation when
it comes to the x-men they didn't
hesitate to assert that only one mutant
would have made it Wolverine
upon being handed a picture of some
popular x-men at Joe Russo said this is
gonna be interesting
yeah I'm gonna do something very
controversial here to the surprise of
the hosts and encouragement from his
brother Jerry began striking team
members willy-nilly taking the time to
point out that even though Thanos wiped
out half of all life in the universe it
doesn't necessarily mean that every
specific group of people would have been
halved and the hawk ice entire family
disappeared yeah so in any given group
you could lose almost everyone in that
group
Bruce owed them presented his handiwork
to gasps from the hosts he explained the
thought process behind his choice is
currently motivated Wolverine going up
against Thanos it stands to reason that
nothing would motivate the near
indestructible hero quite like the only
family he knows being once in the wiped
out by genocide or intergalactic warlord
it would have been quite a contest we
know that Thanos is mighty sword is
capable of damaging vibranium given what
it did to Captain America's shield but
we haven't seen that O's go up against
adamantium the metal that makes up
Wolverines claws and covers a skeleton
and the MCU yet though it has happened
in comics after that difficult choice
the Russos were then presented with a
series of similar scenarios revealing in
each instance which members of popular
groups that would have chosen to dust
for the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Joe
Russo claimed to own a copy of the very
first issue of the comics saying I love
these guys but that doesn't mean he
would have spared them all the choice
was so tough he deferred to Anthony who
benevolently spared them all less the
hosts think him soft though Anthony
deadpan and remember you what you're
talking the guys who eyes
spider-man and Black Panther next up was
scooby-doo and the gang Fred whom Joe
called kind of worthless and Shaggy both
bit the dust presumably leaving Scooby
Velma and Daphne with unstoppable thirst
for vengeance after that the duo was
handed a photo of the cast of friends as
the Russos moose about the slim
likelihood of an entire group having the
misfortune of being totally wiped out
Anthony marked an x over every face at
least Ross wouldn't have to Pine over at
dusted Rachel for five years after
briefly miss identifying a member of the
Backstreet Boys as new kids on the block
Stoney wahlberg the directing brothers
decided to leave only one standing nick
carter they didn't seem to have any
particular reason for this nick just got
lucky
and so ran them anyway you know I
offered a solution genocide but random
his passion is fair to rich and poor
alike having earned the attention of
Marvel Studios partly due to their
excellent work on the beloved series
Arrested Development's deciding which
includes two wipeouts had to have been a
tough choice for the Russos to make
maybe Buster and Tobias orbit the dust
with Anthony explaining that Tobias had
to go because he thought it would be
funny to hear the blue man's final words
with David Cross doing 40 variations on
the line for the cast of another comedy
that brothers worked on community
Pierce Hawthorne got dusted with Anthony
noting that he quote could use the five
years Jo them mused over what choices
would be heartbreaking narrative Lee
before finally choosing to spare
everyone else Disney's deal to require
Fox didn't go through soon enough for an
epic Throwdown between Wolverine and
Thanos to become a reality but Logan
will surely be a big part of the MCU at
some point in the future if Thanos ever
manages to return viewers might get to
see them go head-to-head and Wolverine
has gotten the better of the Titan once
or twice in the comics check out one of
our newest videos right there plus even
more loop of videos about the MCU are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]